Speaker 1: The anti maskers are getting even
more disgusting, if you can imagine that,
at Hawthorne Elementary School in Beverly
Hills, California, a group of anti maskers
showed up with signs and fliers protesting
mask rules.
And they are accosting children at school.
They're accosting kids, telling them, among
other things, don't wear the mask.
The mask smells bad, the mask is bad.
These are kids doing what their parents and
the school have decided they're going to do.
And the protesters show up and tell them not
to wear masks.
Let's look at one clip.
It's visual mostly, but you'll also, just
from listening, get a little bit of a sense
of the atmosphere.
Low.
And I a big they are handing out fliers to
children, and in this next clip, you will
actually hear a protester telling a kid, I'm
sure you hate that mask.
I'm sure it smells bad.
Don't wear it
Speaker 2: is
Unidentified: a wonderful after to be.
We all know what I liked about their kids.
Speaker 1: Sometimes you do something that
isn't that fun because it's what the rules
are and because of some greater good.
I'm the first one to say I don't think the
outdoor masking has ever made sense.
And we're now hearing from more medical doctors
who are basically saying the same thing.
But the indoor masking does make a difference.
And aside from the depraved nature of telling
kids to ignore the health guidelines that
a school has established, don't they realize
that these are children?
It is incredibly intimidating for adults to
show up and talk to kids like this and yell
stuff at them.
And one of the impressions I got from watching
video of the protesters is that there's a
real kind of like Kuhnen stop the steel type
energy or vibe to these people, not just their
physical appearance, which is definitely part
of it, but just the demeanor, everything about
it.
And I was looking around at different commentaries
on this.
And John Scott Railton from the University
of Toronto tweeted about the exact same thing,
saying, quote, Context some may find interesting.
A lot of stop the steel movement energy.
Ditto.
Kuhnen has poured into an anti vaccine agitating
prepare for more of this kind of thing.
And of course, it's borne out in the numbers.
We know that 43 percent of Republicans don't
want to get the vaccine.
They're some of the primary drivers of the
anti vaccine sentiment.
In addition, we know that both Russia and
China are operating on social media to foment
anti vaccine sentiment.
And, of course, as the 2016 election showed
us and other examples, older right wingers
are the most likely to fall for amplifying
what I would call destabilizing propaganda
from foreign countries.
And, of course, what better way to destabilize
the U.S. than to encourage people not to do
the one thing that will get us out of the
pandemic, which is get vaccinated.
Now, there are lots of questions about whether
this type of of, quote, protest is protected
by the First Amendment as a general principle.
It is showing up there and holding signs that
say no masks or whatever.
But one might imagine that when it comes to
starting to yell at children at their school,
when it comes to strangers approaching kids
at school, doesn't it go over into harassment?
Certainly standing there, not blocking the
sidewalk, holding an anti mask sign?
Absolutely.
No question about that.
But they also appear to sort of be blocking
the sidewalk.
They may be interfering with kids getting
in and out of school.
They're yelling at children.
And of course, if anyone tried to shut them
down, they would immediately say, this is
the government silencing us, taking our First
Amendment right.
I'm not even suggesting they be shut down.
It's better to tell the kids to ignore them,
maybe even set up a way to get kids in and
out of school without being subject to this.
I have no idea if that's possible, given the
layout, but is there no limit to this where
we're now talking about yelling at children,
harassing little kids about masks?
Maybe there should be some buffer zone law
like there is with campaigning at polling
places where.
Sure, listen, you have a First Amendment right.
You can campaign for whoever you want.
You can hold signs.
But on Election Day, you have to be a certain
distance from where people are voting.
Otherwise, it could be considered intimidation.
Maybe there's something with schools as well,
because we're talking about kids.
I don't know.
I'm thinking out loud here.
They're almost turning the school into the
same type of gantlet that anti-abortion activists,
activists will try to turn the entrance area
to a medical clinic for women considering
an abortion.
It's a similar type of harassment, except
more vile because these are children who are
going by what their parents and school officials
are saying are going to be the rules.
As a country, when you see video of anti maskers
yelling at children and harassing kids at
school, that doesn't bode well for the United
States as a country.
When you see that that's a red flag, that
things may be going in a very bad direction.
Let me know your thoughts.
We're going to have more coverage of this
on our Instagram page.
You can find The David Pakman Show on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
Speaker 1: . You can also find me on Instagram
at David Pakman.